Castonguay.
Bonjour tout le monde. J'ai le
plaisir de vous annoncer que la
campagne électorale va
déclencher officiellement le 28
août prochain. Je vais mettre
François Legault au défi sur
l'économie. L'économie va être
la question de l'urne. On a
besoin d'avoir le plus de
députés écologistes possibles à
l'Assemblée nationale et chaque
député qu'on ajoute c'est de la
pression qu'on met pour que le
Québec enfin prenne le virage
nécessaire dans la lutte aux
changements climatiques. Tant
quà moi il y a un besoin pour
un troisième lien pour moi
c'est comme une évidence. Reste
à décider que c'est un pont ou
un tunnel nous on souhaite un
tunnel. Si le système public
est pas capable de vous offrir
un service dans des délais
raisonnables, à ce moment-là
vous avez le droit d'aller dans
le système privé. Si on
décidait nous-mêmes de nos
budgets pis qu'on prenait nos
propres décisions comme
Québécoises et Québécois, on
serait pas pris à quémander
comme toutes les provinces
canadiennes, des sommes aussi
majeurs que 6 milliards de
dollars. La seule solution à ça
c'est l'indépendance du Québec.
Rebonjour, bienvenue à notre
émission spéciale sur euh les
élections québécoises 2022
diffusées en direct du plateau
W sur la mezzanine de la
nouvelle maison de
Radio-Canada. Nous passerons la
prochaine heure à répondre à
vos questions avec nos invités.
Évidemment je me suis préparé
quelques questions de mon creux
quand même à moi aussi. Mais
avec nos invités Marie-Hélène
Tremblay qui est analyste
politique à Radio-Canada.
Bonjour Marie-Hélène. Bonjour
Alex. Chantal Hébert,
chroniqueur politique au
magazine l'Actualité et au
Toronto Star. Bonjour Chantal.
Bonjour Alex. Miche COG,
chroniqueur politique à la
presse et à Radio-Canada.
Bonjour Michel. Et euh Philippe
Fournier euh créateur des sites
Québec cent-vingt-cinq, 338
Canada, spécialiste des
sondages et des projections de
sièges. Bonjour Philippe.
Bonjour Alec. Alors euh on a eu
beaucoup de questions de nos
euh auditeurs. Il y en a qu'on
a nous-même choisi mais on veut
faire d'abord en fait on va y
aller en trois temps. On va
faire un peu un bilan de la
campagne. Ensuite parler du
contenu, des promesses, des
engagements. On va terminer
avec les choses à surveiller,
l'impact que ça peut avoir
lundi sur les différents
partis. Marie-Hélène, on a
passé toute la campagne
électorale vous et moi
ensemble. Chaque journée vous
avez scruté les points de
presse, les itinéraires des
différents chefs, les promesses
en euh en détails. Qu'est-ce
que vous qu'est-ce que vous
avez retenu sur le déroulement
sur la dynamique de la
campagne? Ben disons que cinq
cinq euh chefs, cinq partis, ça
représentait un certain défi.
Euh j'ai calculé environ une
centaine de points de presse,
une centaine de mêlées de
presse. Alors faites-le contre.
Il y en a eu beaucoup. Il y en
a eu de de toutes sortes aussi.
Euh du côté de la Coalition
Avenir Québec qui avait
pourtant choisi un slogan, un
continuons ben parfois on
pouvait se demander si François
Legault avait réellement envie
de continuer d'avoir un
deuxième mandat parce que
justement ça a pas été toujours
facile pour lui. Des débats
difficiles. Du côté du Parti
Libéral on l'a souvent dit une
campagne difficile pour
Dominique Anglade du début à la
fin euh véritablement. Québec
Solidaire pourtant une bonne
lancée, un déclenchement euh
qui a quand même été euh
frappant, marquant pour euh la
troupe euh de Québec Solidaire.
Mais euh ça s'est vite
essoufflé. Un bon premier
débat, mais ensuite on dirait
qu'on a perdu un peu le
momentum du côté de Québec
Solidaire. Dans le cas du Parti
Québécois, bien Paul St-Pierre
Plamondon euh s'est fait
connaître euh c'est
essentiellement ce à quoi a
servi le début de sa campagne a
eu de bons débats. S'en est
tenu à son plan de match. Il
l'aura respecté du début à la
fin. Enfin le parti j'ai envie
de dire c'est un peu la
campagne de l'autoroute 20
entre Québec et Montréal
essentiellement la région de
Québec euh une campagne
justement où il a beaucoup de
surfer Éric Duhaime sur le
mécontentement des électeurs
euh est-ce que ça lui aura
permis justement de faire le
plein on a senti à un certain
moment un essoufflement et que
là on avait atteint justement
le maximum qu'il pouvait aller
chercher. Une campagne euh
l'autoroute vingt ça ça me fait
penser à François Legault
2012, il avait fait aussi pas
mal une campagne comme ça de la
grande région de Québec aller
chercher les appuis pour son
euh nouveau parti. Je rappelle
qu'on est diffusé en direct sur
Facebook, sur les pages de
Radio-Canada Information. Euh
également sur ICI Première. Si
vous avez des questions à poser
à nos euh panélistes, euh
hésitez pas, écrivez-nous dans
les commentaires. On on a on a
des euh des lecteurs assidus,
des recherchistes qui regardent
ça, qui vont pouvoir me les
transmettre euh évidemment si
ça s'insère bien dans la
conversation, hésitez pas. Euh
Michel, vous avez couvert pas
mal de campagne électorale euh
en quoi celle-ci est peut-être
différente des autres. Je pense
pas que je me souvienne d'une
campagne électorale où les
mouvements ont jamais dépassé
la marge d'erreur des sondages.
On va se retrouver avec
probablement lundi soir un
pourcentage de votes assez
similaires au premier sondage
de la campagne. C'est dû au
fait qu'il y a quatre partis
d'opposition. C'est dû au fait
aussi qu'il y a pas eu
d'événements majeurs qui euh
souvent viennent bouleverser
une campagne. Il y en a pas eu
cette fois-ci. Euh cette
campagne-là qui est partie sur
euh le thème de protéger les
gens sur l'inflation a bifurqué
très rapidement sur autre
chose. Hum hum. Et à la fin on
a eu plus des des campagnes de
personnalité pis des campagnes
d'idées. Euh ça donc euh on on
va se retrouver avec la
difficulté qu'on avait prévue
au départ, c'est-à-dire cinq
partis, quatre partis
d'opposition qui se à peu près
au coude à coude pis un parti
qui euh à cause du du du mode
de scrutin risque de se
retrouver avec euh beaucoup
plus de sièges qu'il n'a de
voix. Chantal, comment vous
qualifieriez cette campagne
électorale? Hum il y a deux
sortes de campagnes, il y a des
campagnes euh électorales qui
sont des campagnes de
changement, d'autres qui sont
des campagnes de continuité.
Euh et on va revenir au langue
corporelle de monsieur Legault
c'est sûr. Mais on est plus euh
et et pour la première fois
depuis 2008, on serait plus
dans une campagne de
continuité. C'est-à-dire que
après 2008, c'est Jean Charest
qui remporte sa majorité pis
après ça on on essaye trois
parties un après l'autre, un
seul mandat pour Pauline
Maouin, un seul mandat pour
Philippe Couillard pis François
Legault arrive alors on
reviendrait à ce qui était une
habitude. L'habitude du
deuxième mandat, ça donne
toujours des campagnes un petit
peu moins mouvementées. ce que
si il y avait de différentes
deux autres grosses
différences, j'ai jamais vu de
campagne où 5 partis étaient
couverts de façon aussi
paritaire. Et j'inclus le
fédéral là-dedans, c'est pas
vrai qu'on couvre le Parti vert
comme on a couvert le parti
conservateur au Québec. Hum
hum. Au concours, oui le bloc à
l'extérieur du Québec comme on
a couvert le Parti Québec ois.
Et ça change la dynamique.
C'est probablement un avantage
pour François Legault parce que
quatre oppositions qui sont
couverts également, c'est ça
rend plus difficile de coaliser
l'opposition. c'est
probablement bon aussi pour les
quatre parce que à cause de la
pandémie François Legault avait
occupé tellement l'espace que
ces chefs-là avaient pas
vraiment eu la chance de se
faire connaître pis la dernière
différence est frappante cette
semaine je sais pas vous Michel
j'ai jamais couvert un gagnant
qui avait autant l'air d'un
mauvais gagnant qui était
d'aussi mauvaise humeur alors
qui clairement va remporter son
pari. Je l'ai reçu en entrevue
mercredi il m'a dit non j'ai
beaucoup de plaisir tout va
bien mais j'ai failli lui dire
ben peut-être que votre visage
devrait en témoigner puisque
c'est pas, ça semble pas
toujours le cas effectivement.
Ça c'est ce que je dis euh à ma
dentiste que j'aime beaucoup
d'autre part. Votre dentiste.
Philippe euh Jifournier vous
êtes spécialiste, vous avez
regardé toutes les euh les
sondages, intentions de vote
euh est-ce que effectivement on
assiste à une euh stabilité
comme on euh comme Michel le
disait? Une stabilité comme on
a rarement vu depuis longtemps
au Québec comme Chantal l'a
dit, trois élections
consécutives, trois gagnants
consécutifs. J'ai fait mes
recherches au Canada, c'est
vraiment pas arrivé souvent ça
j'ai vu le libéral Peterson
ensuite Bobray et Michael en
Ontario. Je n'ai pas trouvé
d'autres au Canada de trois
élections consécutives et trois
gagnants. Et là on regarde les
chiffres. La CAQ en moyenne
dans mon modèle est à 39% des
intentions de vote. Donc c'est
à peu près le même niveau que
deux-mille-dix-huit. Mais
l'opposition complètement
divisée. Et comme Michel l'a
mentionné, si on regarde les
premiers sondages de la
campagne, bon le PQ a peut-être
monté d'une poignée de points.
Euh le Parti Libéral a
peut-être descendu de 8 à
seize, mais c'est on reste dans
les mêmes eaux. Et donc on a
une stabilité euh qui euh on va
voir si ça perdure jusque dans
l'urne lundi. On attend les
derniers sondages en fin de
semaine mais pour l'instant ça
n'a vraiment pas bougé. Chantal
est-ce que ça veut dire qu'on a
fait une campagne électorale
pour rien? Non les campagnes
électorales servent toujours à
quelque chose dans ce cas-ci.
Je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
de de d'électeurs mais même de
caquistes et de membres du
caucus euh euh de la Coalition
Avenir Québec. Ils ont regardé
monsieur Legault, un peu
méconnaissable par rapport au
personnage rassembleur là. De
la pandémie. De la pandémie et
qui se sont dit va falloir
qu'on commence à à notre avenir
sans ce chef-là euh dans les
quatre prochaines années et ça
va changer la dynamique à
l'intérieur du gouvernement. La
montée entre guillemets du
Parti conservateur dépendant
des résultats pourrait aussi
changer la conversation à
l'intérieur de la Coalition
Avenir Québec, c'est-à-dire si
on commence à percevoir qu'il y
a vraiment quelque chose de
menaçant à droite. Hum hum. Ça
va influencer les débats. Euh
et j'ai l'impression moi que
Québec Solidaire euh c'est un
échec pour Québec Solidaire euh
où on est en fin de course dans
la mesure où le pari de Québec
c'était se détacher du peloton
en opposition pour devenir
l'opposition officielle à
partir des débats, je dirais à
partir de de de des projets
fiscaux de qui sont des débats
comme tel il a été plutôt bon,
mais c'est vrai que toute la
question de la fiscalité a
collé ça a été comme un frein,
c'est comme euh c'est ça pas
stoppé complètement, mais ça a
enlevé l'élan et on finit la
campagne, ils sont un de
quatre. Alors euh ces matières
à réflexion on peut alimenter
tant qu'on voudra euh sur le
projet de Québec Solidaire,
mais ça n'a pas passé Michel
euh est-ce que il y a des
moments particuliers de cette
campagne qui vous ont marqué?
Moi je pense que ça a été la
campagne où des gens ont connu
un moment donné quelque chose
qui a fait qui a eu un arrêt de
croissance. Des gens qui
étaient sur une lancée. Chantal
a parlé de la de la taxe
orange. Oui pour le pour Québec
Solidaire ça a été un véritable
problème. Et surtout que ça
avait l'air d'une taxe
idéologique. L'impôt sur la
fortune dans certains
socialistes français ça. Euh
c'est pas dans nos habitudes à
nous. Euh et ils l'ont défendu
jusqu'à la dernière seconde euh
sans admettre que il y avait
peut-être euh on peut peut-être
considérer que quelqu'un qui a
qui a acheté un trépied avec
ses 30 ans sur la Rosemont est
millionnaire mais c'est pas ça
lui donne pas un train de vie
millionnaire. Monsieur Duhaime
était sur une belle lancée
quand l'affaire de ses impôts
est payée sont arrivées est
arrivée ça a cassé son élan
complètement les deux autres
ont eu euh je parle des partis
de l'opposition là euh madame
Anglade ça n'a jamais décollé
et c'est ça qui est le problème
c'est que euh elle est comme
restée sur les blocs de départ
le PQ un peu l'inverse c'est
que plus on a découvert Paul
St-Pierre Plamondon donc plus
il devenait sympathique mais on
n'a pas beaucoup parlé de ses
propositions non plus mais euh
monsieur Legault euh j'ai j'ai
un ami qui a été dans plusieurs
cabinets qui m'a dit il
vieillit vite pis il vieillit
mal et le problème qu'il va
avoir je suis en train de lui
faire allusion c'est que le
lendemain de l'élection c'est
le début de quand est-ce qu'il
part et euh et et dans un parti
qui l'a lui-même créé c'est un
peu la situation de René
Lévesque au Parti Québécois à
la fin là c'est plus difficile
de mettre le boss dehors quand
il s'est créé le parti mais en
même temps il y a pas mal de
monde qui commence à dire
qu'ils vont commencer à dire à
moins qu'ils se ils que tout
revienne à au beau fixe après
l'élection ce qui est pas
certain qui va dire ben
peut-être c'est le temps qui
s'en aille. Il y a
l'immigration a quand même
beaucoup Michel retenu
l'attention. Du côté de la
Coalition Avenir Québec on
finit les les deux dernières
semaines un peu euh empêtrées
dans différentes déclarations
là. Ça a pas été simple sur
cette question-là. Ça a pas été
simple et et ça ressemblait
bien franchement un peu à des
campagnes de peur là. Quand on
dit si on a plus que euh que
vingt 50 000 immigrants par
année c'est euh suicidaire pour
la nation québécoise. On peut
plus avoir de discussion là.
Euh on qu'est-ce que vous
voulez, le président de la
Chambre de commerce dit moi
j'ai j'ai un j'ai j'ai un autre
chiffre pis j'ai une autre
façon de voir ça. On est en
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre,
peut-être qu'on peut discuter
de ça. Tu te fais dire non non,
c'est suicidaire cette
affaire-là. Euh on peut plus
avoir de discussion. Euh je
pense que là-dessus ils ont
poussé le bouchon un petit peu
trop fort. On a une question
d'un de nos auditeurs ****
Sans-Cartier, Michel justement
sur l'immigration et je vous la
lis. Est-ce qu'il vous est venu
à l'idée que la controverse sur
l'immigration on parle de ça,
provoquée par François Legault
visé peut-être à faire sortir
son vote? il y a toujours dans
dans des dossiers comme ceux-là
la possibilité et je ne dis pas
que c'est c'est volontairement
ce qu'ils ont fait mais la
possibilité est là de dire
voici ce que les gens pensent
tout bas mais ne disent pas
tout haut on on va au moins
envoyer le le l'appel du pied
que c'est ça qu'on pense nous
autres aussi on peut pas
enlever cette possibilité-là en
même temps on peut pas
consonder les raisins et les
coeurs pour savoir quel est le
le sentiment profond cela dit
euh la Coalition Avenir Québec
partait avec une longueur
d'avance et dans ses objectifs
euh qualitatifs pas
quantitatifs parce qu'ils
avaient pas besoin de s'en
soucier tellement il y avait
euh plus de terrain sur l'île
de Montréal. Oui, c'est vrai.
Euh et et c'est important.
C'est pas c'est pas sain
d'avoir un gouvernement et je
pense que monsieur Legault
serait d'accord avec ce
concept-là d'avoir un
gouvernement euh qui le reste
du Québec est pas Montréal.
Hum. Mais euh le le l'épisode
sur l'immigration ça va aussi
faire sortir du vote qui risque
de faire que ces gains-là
espérés par la Coalition Avenir
Québec vont pas se matérialiser
parce que et on les entend là
avec raison beaucoup euh
d'électeurs qui disent moi je
parle français, je suis venu
ici il y a 30 ans, mes enfants
sont allés à l'école en
français et et là le ministre
de l'Immigration dit non
seulement que je parle pas
français mais que je travaille
pas mais faut le faire là. On a
eu une question d'ailleurs d'un
auditeur **** Leblanc de
Longueuil, je je la pose à à
Marie-Hélène sa question était
euh on n'a pas soulevé
l'hypothèse du suicide
politique comme certains l'ont
fait dans le passé en volant
des gants ou un veston je pense
qu'on fait réfé à Claude
Charron en janvier mille-neuf-ce
trop gros, trop grave comme
déclaration pour ne pas
invoquer une hypothèse de la
sorte, qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez? Ben monsieur Leblanc a
raison quand il dit que c'est
une déclaration justement qui
est grave, surtout qu'elle
n'est pas euh comme le disait
Chantal le reflet de de la
réalité. Hum hum. Euh reste que
monsieur Boulay a accordé
quelques entrevues s'est
confondu euh en excuse euh
n'empêche euh la question
justement du suicide politique
a pas été nécessairement abordé
dans ces entrevues-là Moi pas
sous cet angle-là. Jean Boulet
a plutôt la réputation d'être
un gentil homme comme on dit.
Euh fait très peu d'erreurs là
durant euh son mandat. Bon
évidemment euh François Legault
a été clair là-dessus et ça le
disqualifie comme ministre de
l'Environnement. De vous voulez
dire de l'immigration. De
l'immigration pardon n'empêche
euh à voir justement si
effectivement François Legault
fait davantage le plein de
députés euh lundi soir. Euh
est-ce que ça lui garantit pour
autant de place sur le Conseil
des ministres euh à voir mais
n'empêche qu'effectivement euh
Jean Boulay s'est s'est
assurément tiré dans le pied
avec cette déclaration-là.
D'ailleurs on a une question de
Johanne qui demande euh quel
est le poids réel des gaffes de
certains candidats bénévoles
hein on voit là des des euh
déclarations euh controversé
dans le passé, il y en a eu
chez des candidats
conservateurs, il y en a chez
des candidats péquistes même
encore aujourd'hui là qui qui
ressortent. Euh est-ce que ça
pèse Chantal dans les campagnes
électorales sur ce type de
gaffe là? Ça dépend combien il
y en a et de quel parti il est
question. C'est-à-dire que par
exemple et je dis pas que
Québec Solidaire a accumulé ce
genre de candidat, mais un
parti moins établi qui a une
une enfilade de ce genre de
candidat-là. Ce serait euh plus
le cas par exemple du Parti
Conservateur du Québec. Euh ça
va faire que les électeurs, on
le sait, ils sont pas prêts.
Euh quand on couvrait euh à
l'époque le Parti réformiste
qui tentait de s'imposer à
l'extérieur des prairies et
qu'on sortait systématiquement
l'enfilade de candidats qui
disait à peu près n'importe
quoi c'est sûr qu'en Ontario
les électeurs regardaient ça et
ils disaient non non non la la
phrase anglaise for prime time
là on est pas prêt pour euh euh
et mais autrement un incident
de parcours ici et là non là je
pense que la plupart des
électeurs se disent ça arrive
qu'on se plante pas la même
chose quand c'est le ministre
de l'Immigration évidemment.
Qui devrait normalement ou le
premier ministre effectivement.
Euh Philippe question de euh
euh Chautard qui parle vous
disiez tout à l'heure les
sondages ont pas bougé beaucoup
effectivement. Euh elle dit euh
bon euh personne n'avait venu
venir l'élection à Sherbrooke
ou à Rouyn-Noranda de Québec
Solidaire en 208. Est-ce que
même si ça ne bouge pas sur le
point euh le plan national, ça
veut pas dire dans le fond
qu'on est capable de bel et
bien savoir où il va y avoir
des surprises? Est-ce qu'on
peut encore se se fier à aux
aux aux sondages. C'est sûr que
je vais avoir un bémol
là-dessus. On avait vu la
montée de Québec Solidaire. On
avait pas vu la victoire mais
on avait vu que c'était tout à
fait plausible et c'est un peu
la même chose présentement.
Québec Solidaire est compétitif
dans peut-être 14 ou 15
circonscriptions. Il ne va pas
toutes les gagner. Mais une
bonne soirée, une bonne sortie
de vote très régionalisée.
Peut-être que ça pourrait être
14 15 sièges. Mais la
régionalisation du vote en
effet écoutez si on regarde les
projections actuelles et là
bien sûr il y a encore une
marge d'erreur là-dedans, on
s'entend. Mais la CAQ pourrait
gagner deux sièges sur vingt à
Montréal et en gagner
quatre-vingt-dix sur
quatre-vingt-dix-huit hors de
Montréal. Et là c'est vraiment
un débalancement important.
Deux sièges sur 27, c'est le
même résultat pour la CAQ à
Montréal mais quatre-vingt-dix
au quatre-vingt-dix-huit c'est
bien plus élevé que 2018 et et
et on voit on a eu des sondages
locaux Alec euh en Mauricie au
Saguenay. Il y en a eu beaucoup
quand même. Il y a eu beaucoup
de sondages locaux. Est-ce
qu'on remarque vraiment le PQ
et le PLQ sont complètement
dégringolés en région. Et et la
CAQ a augmenté. Pourtant au
niveau national, la CAQ est à
peu près au même niveau Donc
est-ce que ça nous dit ça? Ça
veut dire la CAQ a perdu dans
les centres urbains
particulièrement à Québec et à
Montréal. Et et cette
régionalisation-là n'est pas
nécessairement saine. On a une
question de Sam euh Jarouche
qui a vingt ans. Euh Michel je
vais vous l'adresser à vous. Il
veut euh c'est sur le PQ et
Québec Solidaire. Euh il note
que euh bon euh Québec
Solidaire qui est un parti
souverainiste parvient à
rejoindre les jeunes parce
qu'il parle davantage d'avenir
qui se demande si le PQ a de la
difficulté à joindre la tranche
d'âge des dix-huit
trente-quatre ans parce dans
les sondages parce que le PQ
est pas en train de parler de
ce qui se passait en
mille-neuf-cent-quatre-vingt ou
en mille-neuf-cent-quatre-vingt-
QS ne fait que parler d'avenir.
C'est une jolie histoire que
celle du PQ, mais le film ne
colle plus vraiment à la
réalité. Qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez? Une partie des
problèmes du Parti Québécois
est effectivement le l'espèce
de passéisme mais que que que
Paul Sabia Plamondon essaie de
ne pas incarner, mais une fois
de temps en temps il est obligé
de revenir à l'argumentaire
traditionnel du PQ, on peut pas
être le PQ sans dire un certain
nombre de choses. Euh le le le
problème de Québec Solidaire
est un peu l'inverse. C'est que
oui, ils sont souverainistes,
mais c'est pas le la la clé de
leur programme. Alors un moment
donné, Québec Solidaire est là
pourquoi? Qu'est-ce qu'ils
veulent faire? Euh ils sont ils
sont un peu verts, ils sont un
peu euh souverainistes, ils
sont un peu gauchistes. Tu
sais, c'est c'est quoi
l'identité réelle? Il y a pas
euh une question la question de
l'urne que Québec Solidaire
pourrait poser, pourrait
porter. Alors c'est pas
l'environnement à votre avis
parce qu'on a quand même
beaucoup qui sont les plus
verts de de de tous mais mais
le PQ a un très bon programme
en environnement aussi. On l'a
vu au débat, les deux, les deux
se félicitent habituellement
là. Alors euh c'est c'est c'est
ça le le le le problème un peu
de de de QS pis d'un autre côté
le problème du PQ c'est oui on
est dans un euh malgré tout,
malgré un jeune chef dans un
euh côté assez passéiste, va
faire plus de lois on va se
partir. Euh c'est les solutions
d'hier, on va les reprendre pis
sont encore bonnes. Mais il y a
une raison pour ça après le
référendum de
quatre-vingt-quinze euh et
contre toute attente au sein du
Parti Québécois. Ce qu'on a vu
c'est que la clientèle
souverainiste, celle qui
voulait un référendum, mais qui
voulait voter oui,
vieillissait. Et que les
générations, les nouvelles
tranches d'électeurs suivaient
pas. À un moment donné, Bernard
Landry disait euh les personnes
âgées sont fédéralistes et
elles s'en vont toutes. On s'en
occupe. Parce que les jeunes
sont automatiquement qui me
souvient. Et ce qui est arrivé
c'est plutôt qu'il est resté la
génération des baby-boomers
mais que dans les autres
tranches d'âge d'un sondage et
d'une année à l'autre on a vu
l'appui euh à la souveraineté
baisser. Donc si le PQ est en
train de se battre pour sa
survie ça a du bon sens de
parler du passé. Parce qu'il
s'adresse à des gens qui
étaient là et qui sont sa
meilleure clientèle pis en plus
qui ont l'avantage d'aller
voter plus assidument que les
tranches les plus jeunes. Pis
les dernières publicités du PQ
c'est revenez à la maison
littéralement. Alors euh
s'adresse pas aux ça s'adresse
aux baby-boomers, ça s'adresse
pas à aux plus jeunes ça.
Parlons un peu de contenu des
euh plateformes électorales, on
a eu plusieurs questions.
Marie-Hélène bon il y a eu
énormément de propositions,
vous parlez tout à l'heure de
cinq partis, ça fait énormément
de de choses à discuter. Est-ce
que il y a des des des points
précis, des choses qu'on
devrait retenir de certaines
propositions euh les partis
politiques? En fait la première
semaine, l'ensemble des partis
là c'est c'était ça se
disputait les baisses d'impôts,
les chèques euh disons pour
justement qu'on euh la flambée
de l'inflation on avait même
nous là de la difficulté à s'y
retrouver euh même la même
journée François Legault et
Dominique Anglade ont fait pour
ainsi dire la même proposition
en euh de en voulant donner
deux en donner 2000 $ aux
personnes âgées de plus de
soixante-dix ans alors si nous
on avait du mal à s'y retrouver
je présume que c'était la même
chose aussi pour les électeurs,
surtout en début de campagne
euh parce que les gens sont
moins attentifs et euh on on le
dit une campagne à l'automne
après la FED travail, les gens
commencent justement à
s'intéresser davantage à la
campagne électorale. Euh il y a
quand même des choses aussi
dont on a très très peu parlé.
On a parlé évidemment
d'immigration, on a parlé
abondamment du troisième lien.
Oui, beaucoup. Là aussi,
rappelez-vous cette déclaration
de François Legault en disant
que les gens de Montréal
regardez les gens de Québec de
haut. Euh alors ça aussi ça
avait fait quand même pas mal
de bruit. Mais on a très très
peu parlé d'éducation alors que
François Legault se se targue à
dire que s'il est en politique
c'est justement pour la cause
de l'éducation et on on l'a vu,
on a été en pleine rentrée
scolaire, il manque encore des
enseignants, du personnel
spécialisé euh le transport
scolaire est déficient et on a
très peu parlé en bout de piste
d'éducation durant la campagne.
Est-ce que Michel, Chantal il y
a des engagements qui vous ont
marqué davantage Michel? Il y a
pas vraiment d'engagement qui
on peut dire on réussit à faire
changer la campagne. Euh il y a
des bonnes idées. Euh il y a il
y a des choses qui sont
intéressant je parlais des des
des euh programmes
environnementaux et du PQ et de
Québec Solidaire, il y a des
choses là-dedans qui sont
intéressantes et qui devraient
être regardées. Mais euh j'ai
pas vu un engagement qui a
réussi à à enflammer la
campagne à l'inverse euh le
principal problème de madame
Anglade, ça a été précisément
d'avoir des engagements qui
touchaient pas les qui
touchaient pas les gens. C'est
beau l'histoire de de
l'hydrogène vert, mais c'est un
carburant qu'on va peut-être
vendre aux Allemands dans
vingt, trente ans. Euh on n'a
pas rendu et les gens se sont
pas reconnus là-dedans et ça eu
l'air d'un programme qui qui
venait d'en haut pis qui
arrivait nulle part. Une
promesse de qui reste, il faut
qu'elle soit différente de
l'offre d'à peu près euh tout
ce qui se présente autour donc
euh le PQ euh et QS euh sont
neutralisés mutuellement sur
euh la question climatique et
et la base des millions de la
première semaine, le premier
résultat ça a été neutralisé
euh l'enjeu de l'inflation et
de comment on y répond. Et le
la deuxième condition de cette
promesse qui reste c'est aussi
qu'elle ne devienne pas la taxe
orange dans cette campagne-ci,
c'est-à-dire euh quelque chose
qui fait reculer la formation
ou qui ou qui la lui fait faire
du sur place, c'est la dernière
fois qu'on en a vu une promesse
comme ça, oser mais qui a quand
même marché. C'est Justin
Trudeau qui promet de faire des
déficits. Ouais. Et la plupart
d'entre nous qui étaient là
pour la lutte au déficit, on se
demande on n'a pas pu venir,
mais au début on s'est dit quel
scénario euh dangereux. Ben
oui. Ben oui, le Parti libéral
va payer euh une facture. Je
pense quand même sur un
dossier, le troisième lien dont
on a beaucoup parlé, même si on
est à Montréal, on va en
reparler. Euh il y a occasion
manquée pour euh la Coalition
Avenir Québec. C'est-à-dire que
la majorité des gens qui soient
à Montréal ou ailleurs
s'étaient pas fait une tête sur
le troisième lien. Et c'était
une belle occasion pour la CAQ
tant quà en parler d'expliquer
son projet et sa démarche de
façon à ce que des gens qui
sont pas engagés d'un côté
comme à l'autre se disent
finalement je suis peut-être
pas une si mauvaise affaire ou
ils ont des bons arguments. Et
c'est le contraire qui s'est
passé. Si vous étiez pas vendu
à l'idée du troisième lien et
que vous avez regardé la
campagne de la coalition Avenir
Québec, vous l'êtes
certainement pas plus
aujourd'hui, après vous vous
êtes fait dire qu'il y a pas
d'études que quoi disent on va
le faire pareil, que la
population va baisser, mais non
c'est pas grave parce que ils
vont arriver comme euh et et ça
c'est une occasion ratée qui va
revenir hantée je crois euh le
gouvernement caquiste s'il est
reconduit euh la semaine
prochaine. Marie-Hélène on a
une question euh de qui vient
de de Facebook là d'un de nos
euh d'une de nos auditrices
Marie Meunier comment
interprètez-vous le fait que
les chefs ont été pas mal seuls
sur scène? Nous n'avons pas vu
beaucoup de personnalités
autour des chefs notamment au
Parti Libéral pour appuyer par
Dominique Anglade. C'est vrai
que les libéraux ont été
absents. On on le disait aussi
au niveau de l'organisation euh
libérale euh on a vraiment
l'impression que les les les
disons les organisateurs
libéraux sont restés à la
maison. Euh ils n'étaient pas
là. Euh il y a eu bien sûr
Carlos Laita qui était là. Ceux
qui quittent justement parce
qu'il y en a quand même treize
des vingt-sept députés libéraux
qui ont quitté euh à cette
élection-ci. Mais c'est vrai
que les autres n'y étaient pas.
Euh on pourrait dire en fait il
y a il y a Paul St-Pierre
Plamondon quand même qui a
réussi à ramener euh et on pu
lire et entendre certains vieux
péquistes hum hum. Justement
qui ont repris le service. Il a
fait campagne avec François
Gendron notamment, Louise
Beaudoin qui a écrit aussi. Euh
du côté euh de Québec Solidaire
Françoise David, mais très peu.
Hum hum. Et euh vraiment il a
il y a pas eu d'artiste non
plus. Beaucoup qui se sont
affichés avec les chefs
notamment euh c'est souvent le
cas pour euh les les parties
souverainistes. Ouais. Hum. On
a vu Daniel Boucher en
Gaspésie. Mais c'est à peu près
tout. Alors effectivement, il y
a eu une absence de de vedette,
qu'elle soit politique ou
qu'elle soit sur le milieu du
milieu artistique. Philippe hum
est-ce que le dans les euh on
regarde dans les les
projections de sièges, est-ce
que le le candidat, sa
notoriété a un impact? Est-ce
qu'on peut aller chercher une
circonscription parce qu'on est
un candidat vedette ou la
campagne nationale écrase
tellement tout que ça a peu
d'impact? La réponse à ça euh
elle est bon la question est
bonne c'est très rare. Dans le
sens que il y a eu des sondages
là-dessus à répétition. On voit
qu'environ 10 à 15 % des
électeurs votez pour un
candidat avant le parti et le
chef. Mais il reste que
quatre-vingt-cinq pour cent
vont dire le parti et le chef.
Euh bien sûr dans certaines
circonscriptions on regarde
dans le cas du PQ, Véronique
Hivon, euh Sylvain Gaudreault,
euh monsieur ben oui. Monsieur
Lebel à Rimouski, je veux dire
il y avait des candidats
importants locaux. Euh mais ce
sont des exceptions sur 125
circonscriptions il va
peut-être en avoir une dizaine
de de candidats qui peuvent
vraiment faire une une
différence à eux seuls. Alors
oui les campagnes locales sont
importantes, mais dans une
élection comme la nôtre
présentement c'est pas la
différence ta victoire et la
défaite. Oui Michel, ce qu'on a
pas vu cette année et qu'on
voyait toujours c'était le
parti qui très tôt dans la
campagne présentait son équipe
économique et désignait
pratiquement son ministre des
finances. Oui c'est vrai. À
part le Québec qui bien sûr a
tout ça dans euh très très
clairement dans dans dans sa
brochette de candidat. Personne
s'est soucié de faire ça.
Souvenez-vous monsieur Charest
faisait ça là littéralement au
début de chaque campagne. Voici
mon équipe économique. Voici
qui est mon ministre des
Finances et aucun des partis
des partis de l'opposition est
allé là et Je pense pas qu'il y
ait quelqu'un qui se démarque
dans un parti d'opposition tu
vas dire ah c'est évident que
lui va être ministre des
finances. Ça c'est ça ça prouve
qu'on malgré tout ce qu'on a
dit sur la récession, sur
l'île, l'inflation et tout ça,
ça a pas été une campagne
économique ce qui est quand
même assez euh assez nouveau.
C'est rare, oui. Oui. Mais j'ai
l'impression moi que si les
partis ont pas fait ça, c'est
les parce que l'équipe euh à
aux finances et à la santé de
monsieur Legault euh allaient
de toute façon faire pâlir euh
les gens qui allaient faire
monter sur l'estrade. Alors à
ce moment-là on dit euh c'est
ça Dans le temps où Paul Martin
était ministre des Finances,
Jean Chrétien sortait beaucoup
beaucoup et on sait pas trop
qui aurait été le ministre des
finances des autres. Johanne
Hamel qui pose une question à
Chantal et Michel sur la
fonderie Orne à Rouyn-Noranda.
S'agissant de la fonderie Orn,
est-ce que c'est pas un peu
facile de la part de François
Legault de dire ce sera à la
population de décider est-ce
que ce n'est pas le devoir, la
responsabilité du gouvernement
de fixer les normes et de les
faire respecter afin de
protéger la population et
l'environnement du Québec
Michel. Oui. Effectivement,
c'est le travail du
gouvernement de faire ça et
monsieur Legault essaie de de
en au football on dirait de
faire raboter de dégagement en
disant on va faire un
référendum, on va et les gens
décideront s'ils veulent ces
beaux emplois payants ou s'ils
veulent euh de la qualité de
l'air. C'est mettre les gens
devant un dilemme qui n'a pas
de bon sens. Euh et euh c'est
c'est c'est refuser sa propre
responsabilité là-dedans. Cela
dit euh ça fait partie aussi du
d'un autre euh euh argumentaire
de c'est-à-dire c'est pas aux
gens de Montréal d'aller
décider ça. Euh on l'a entendu
beaucoup, on a entendu ça au
troisième lien. Mais euh quand
monsieur Legault s'est mis à
répéter ça encore hier. Euh je
suis pas sûr qu'il s'est aidé.
C'est surtout euh que c'est pas
aux médecins qui travaillent
dans cette communauté-là de
dire que il faudrait faire
plus. Ça ça c'était particulier
dans la déclaration de François
Legault quand même. Euh et oui
euh il y a une certaine
abdication de leadership à dire
ça parce que la première tâche
de la personne qui va être
premier ministre du Québec la
semaine prochaine dans ce
cas-ci pousser sur la compagnie
pour qu'elle arrive vraiment à
une amélioration de sa
proposition. Ça c'est la
première étape, c'est pas de
faire la campagne de la
compagnie en disant euh des ces
beaux emplois, 100 mille $ par
année là, vous en aurez plus
euh c'est c'est c'est comme si
il était devenu l'homme de la
fonderie Orn. Et ça c'est pas
bon? Ben c'est pas la la c'est
pas le rôle du premier ministre
ou du candidat à Premier
ministre. Philippe Gourny, à
quoi ressemble la course dans
Rouyn-Noranda parce que
François Legault était là cette
semaine. Marie-Hélène nous
disait à l'émission tout à
l'heure c'est quand même osé
d'avoir été faire un tour par
là là dans la dernière semaine
de la campagne. Euh bien des
gens présument qu'il va perdre
mais c'est pas si évident que
ça hein ces euh cette
course-là. Écoutez Émilise
Lessard-Therrien euh avec
Castonguay avait des bons
scores dans de Québec Solidaire
ouais. De Québec Solidaire
avait causé la surprise en
2mille8. On savait qu'elle
allait être compétitive mais
elle s'est faufilée en
deuxmilledix8. Elle a eu 32 %
du vote. Et dans ce temps-là,
32 % du vote, ça veut dire que
un peu comme Denis Coderre à la
mairie, après euh tu dois
essayer d'agrandir ta base. Et
et et ce qu'on voit en région
encore une fois, en
particulièrement en Abitibi, le
vote libéral et le vote
péquiste s'est complètement
effondré et donc est-ce que ces
gens-là vont aller vers Québec
Solidaire? Euh peut-être une
petite partie mais la la CAQ
devrait être considérée comme
favorite dans dans
Rouyn-Noranda-Témiscamingue à
ce point-ci. Marie-Hélène
Tremblay, j'ai une question qui
nous provient de Twitter qui
demande face aux face aux
risques de récession possible
dont on parle davantage. Est-ce
qu'il y a un parti qui vous
semble mieux armé pour
affronter une pos potentielle
crise économique. Est-ce que
dans le fond il y a un parti
qui a euh la carte euh
financière et économique qui a
son avantage? Je veux savoir
cet auditeur-là. En fait la
question ne s'est pas vraiment
posée parce que l'avance est
telle du côté de la Coalition
Avenir Québec qu'on dit que
c'est la Coalition Avenir
Québec qui aura justement à
s'occuper de cette question-là
euh après le trois octobre.
Mais on peut prendre la
question autrement parce que
plusieurs partis ont promis des
baisses d'impôts. C'est le cas
de la CAQ. C'est le cas aussi
euh du Parti euh Libéral et du
Parti conservateur et alors
quand on dit baisse d'impôt on
dit baisse également de la
croissance euh du côté du Parti
conservateur on prévoit aussi
d'importantes compressions qui
ont aussi un effet sur la
croissance de l'économie euh
Québec Solidaire qui dit qu'il
va augmenter les taxes pour les
riches alors on a vu un peu
aussi que ça ça pourrait
également avoir un effet sur
euh la façon dont l'économie du
Québec va se comporter bref hum
autre chose qui risque de faire
peut-être mal justement aux
finances du Québec. C'est cette
décision de piger dans le fond
des générations. Euh ça quand
la Coalition Avenir Québec y
est allée et justement de cet
engagement-là secouer le le
cocotier là à ce moment-là euh
ça oui on l'avait pas vu venir
ça parce que jamais on s'était
commis dans cette direction-là
du côté du ministre Éric Girard
et lorsqu'on a annoncé les
baisses d'impôts on on a dit
qu'on allait réduire euh les
virements euh aux fonds des
générations dans l'ordre de 40
pour du côté de Québec
Solidaire on y met carrément
fin justement pour remplir euh
les promesses liées au au euh
au au plan climat de ce
parti-là. Alors bref euh il
reste que euh faudra voir
comment l'économie va se
comporter si effectivement le
Québec entre en réception. euh
François Legault disait il y a
quelques jours qu'estimait la
la possibilité à 50 %
maintenant. Alors comment va va
ensuite se comporter les
finances du Québec ben ça ça
sera intéressant de surveiller
ça. On a reçu beaucoup de
questions sur le mode de
peut-être qu'on est une
émission d'intellectuel je sais
pas ou mais je me suis pas
battu dans les autobus je vous
le jure c'est pas moi qui a
provoqué ça euh commençons par
Philippe Gi une question qui
vous est adressée par Dominique
Gravel euh je vous la lis. La
CAQ semble casser du dos sur le
sucre sur le sucre cassé du
sucre sur le dos pardon
inverser mes phrases la CAQ
semble casser du sucre sur le
dos de Montréal parce qu'elle
n'a pas besoin des Montréalais
pour l'élection de 2022, est-ce
que les choses seraient
différentes si on avait un
scrutin proportionnel
pourrait-elle se permettre
autant de se de ses votes.
C'est de la politique-fiction,
donc on fait toujours un peu
attention à de telles
hypothèses. Je suis un
scientifique donc hypothèse,
expérimentation conclusion
n'est-ce pas? Et c'est évident
que ce soit un autre mode de
scrutin, euh les intentions de
vote changeraient. Elles ne
changeraient pas
instantanément, ça prendrait
quelques cycles, mais ça
changerait. Et et et là encore
une fois, on voit le clivage
entre Montréal et le reste du
Québec qui est complètement
séparé alors que si euh si
chaque vote avait le même
poids. Je veux dire, j'avais
fait le test en regardant les
chiffres des circonscriptions.
Si on fusionnait Bonaventure et
Gaspé en une seule
circonscription. Il y a 24
circonscriptions du Grand
Montréal qui aurait une
population plus grande que
cette cette nouvelle
circonscription-là. Alors
évidemment le poids en vote des
régions est beaucoup plus
important que Montréal sous un
format proportionnel évidemment
les électeurs auraient tous le
même poids. Mais j'ai fait
l'exercice pour cette
question-là parce que je l'ai
vu venir. Donc euh regarde
Alain Antoine Courchesne qui
veut savoir si on était en mode
de scrutin proportionnel à quoi
ressemblerait résultat avec les
sondages actuels. Très bonne
question. Je répète,
politique-fiction. Oui oui on
s'amuse. on s'amuse ici. Ouais.
Mais euh avec les les
projections de vote actuelles,
un mode de scrutin
proportionnel avec un seuil de
5 %. Donc si en bas de 5 % un
parti n'a aucun siège, la CAQ
aurait 53 sièges en moyenne.
Euh donc ça prend 63 pour une
majorité. Les libéraux
vingt-six, Québec Solidaire
dix-sept, conservateur quinze,
Parti Québec ois 14. Et donc on
aurait une CAQ minoritaire et
tous les partis d'opposition
auraient la balance du pouvoir.
Alors euh qu'il y aurait une
plus de collaboration?
Peut-être mais en terme de
sièges, en terme de support, il
y aurait plusieurs combinaisons
possibles et je pense que pour
certains électeurs, c'est
intéressant. Mais je le répète,
c'est la politique fiction. Euh
il y aurait sûrement beaucoup
plus de partis. Si euh on avait
une c'est ça la la la le
paysage serait différent à la
ligne de départ même là. Ouais,
cela dit, on se retrouverait
avec un gouvernement de la
Coalition Avenir Québec Ouais.
Qui pourrait euh tout très
facilement s'entendre avec le
Parti conservateur pour se
faire une majorité. euh et sur
certaines choses et sur
d'autres peut-être ça serait un
autre problème. Former un
gouvernement de coalition,
donner deux ministères euh pis
euh ou bien une entente comme
celle qu'on voit à Ottawa. Ce
que j'essaie de dire c'est que
les les électeurs qui sont à
gauche de la Coalition Avenir
Québec et donc à gauche du
Parti conservateur loge dans
trois partis, Parti Libéral du
Québec, Québec Solidaire et le
PQ dont j'ai hâte de voir
comment ils feraient pour
s'entendre ensemble pour former
un gouvernement. Parce que
leurs différences sont beaucoup
plus irréconciliables et ça
c'est ce qui a le soi-disant
terrain là gauche Centre droit
donc est occupé par trois
partis qui sont pas capables
d'aller au même party de Noël.
C'est un pensez-y bien parce
que les les apôtres de de la
proportionnelle euh ont
tendance à être des gens qui
s'identifient davantage à la
gauche et au centre gauche quà
la droite. Alors euh peut-être
que ce serait une bonne idée de
regarder le fait que depuis le
début de la campagne plus que
50% des gens qui répondent au
sondage sur les intentions de
vote, votent pour la CAQ ou le
Parti conservateur. Michel
Nicolas Gauthier de
Saint-Bruno-de-Montarville veut
savoir étant donné qu'il y a
quatre partis d'opposition nez
à nez. Euh est-ce que ça
pourrait euh ramener sur le
tapis l'idée de réformer le
mode de scrutin. Est-ce que
dans le fond François Legault
serait obligé de reconsidérer
ça puisqu'il va y avoir de la
pression après les élections?
Il va y avoir de la pression et
c'est un fait que le vainqueur
du scrutin va être le scrutin
uninominal à un tour. Euh qui
dans les faits va garantir à la
CAQ une une très bonne majorité
si c'est pas une super
majorité. Euh oui il faut y
penser en même temps. L'écueil
a toujours été le même. Les
trois partis qui ont qui ont eu
le pouvoir de faire révolution
tranquille, le PQ des libéraux
pis la CAQ ont tous promis le
scrutin proportionnel et ils
ont tous reculer à cause d'une
chose leur caucus en voulait
pas parce que les gars disaient
ah on va peut-être perdre nos
comptés pis à cause du des
proportionnelles pis des
députés de liste pis des
affaires de même. Alors à un
moment donné si tu peux pas le
passer dans ton propre caucus
pense pas que tu vas faire des
grandes réformes. Alors oui ça
va revenir sur le tapis, c'est
ça intéresse peut-être pas les
autobus, mais certainement des
intellectuels. Et mais est-ce
que est-ce qu'ils vont bouger
là-dessus? Moi je ne le crois
plus. Pas grand chose qui euh
mérite une bataille dans
l'autobus hein? Je trouve ça
comme ça là, mais c'est rare
qu'on se bat dans les auto
quand même. Néanmoins de notre
vivante journaliste Michel et
moi euh ma prédiction on verra
pas de système euh
proportionnel ni à Ottawa ni à
Québec. Écoutez encore une fois
la CAQ aurait 40 sièges de
moins en qu'une
proportionnelle. Et donc même
si c'était plus démocratique.
Est-ce que le caucus vraiment
va accepter ça? Et en plus
j'ajouterais rapidement que le
le mouvement démocratie
nouvelle le plan qu'ils avaient
en 2018 était tout croche. Et
donc vous voulez faire une
proportionnelle arriver à
quelque chose de simple et
élégant le le système qu'ils
avaient choisi était vraiment
malfité. Vous dites
quatre-vingt-dix députés
possibles on verra lundi mais
Michel Dion se demande est-ce
que quatre-vingt-dix,
quatre-vingt-douze,
quatre-vingt-treize députés
c'est pas compliqué pour
François Legault à gérer? Ben
oui. En terme de caucus.
D'abord on a pas beaucoup de
clés de limousine à donner.
Deuxièmement euh à chaque fois
qu'il y a eu une super
majorité. Ces dernières années
là, c'est monsieur Bourassa qui
en a eu deux. En
soixante-treize et euh à sa
première réélection. À sa à sa
première réélection justement
dans dans son deuxième mandat.
Les deux fois ils ont perdu À
un moment donné les attentes
sont trop grandes aussi alors
euh c'est c'est un pis l'autre
chose c'est que ça va être un
deuxième mandat pour la CAQ.
Aller en chercher un troisième,
ça c'est difficile. Nommez-moi
un deuxième mandat qui a été un
mandat plus heureux que le
premier et là je parle pas
simplement du Québec pis euh
chaque chaque année ajoute au
poids de fatigue et si on est
pour être sur un décor de
succession entre des factions
plus souverainistes et plus
fédéralistes pas fait ce cette
affaire-là mais ça promet des
des des belles journées.
Marie-Hélène vous êtes à
l'Assemblée national ce sera
pas simple à gérer ce
caucus-là? Ce ce sera quelques
têtes fortes aussi hein c'est
ben oui tout à fait on on peut
le penser parce que oui
effectivement Chantal le disait
il y a il y a une frange un peu
plus souverainiste là le nom de
Simon Joly-Barrette me vient en
tête celui de Bernard
Drainville aussi et du côté
fédéraliste davantage Geneviève
Guilbault on on sait que Lebel
laisse pas sa place non plus
mais y aller avec quelques uns.
Il y a certaines certains
aspirent à à à mieux à prendre
justement la place de François
Legault. Alors ce ce sera
simple si effectivement le la
réelle opposition sera
peut-être même dans son caucus
parce qu'il va y avoir des
factions qui vont
nécessairement se disputer euh
la première place et on l'a vu
il y a pas eu beaucoup de
ramaniements ministériels non
plus durant le mandat de
François Legault son conseil
des ministres. Plusieurs ont eu
le même ministère pendant 4 ans
ce qui est quand même assez
rare euh ce qui a forcé
d'ailleurs euh la la fonction
publique à travailler davantage
nous dit-on là parce que un
ministre qui qui a posé et qui
a qui avait des à la première
année, il y en avait aussi à la
deuxième, à la troisième et à
la quatrième. Alors on peut
penser, il y aura
nécessairement beaucoup de
déçus si on on atteint
effectivement le chiffre de
quatre-vingt-dix et plus
député, c'est pas tout le monde
effectivement comme disait
Michel qui aura des limousines.
Alors il y en aura certains qui
n'auront pas justement de de
portefeuille qui seront
assurément déçus. Chantal, il y
a deux chefs qui sont en quête
d'un siège à l'Assemblée
nationale, Paul St-Pierre
Plamondon, Éric Duhaime. Est-ce
que pour eux, c'est davantage
important de gagner leur siège
ou d'avoir plus de vol en terme
de pourcentage à l'Assemblée
nationale. C'est même pas un
concours. Hum. Gagner un siège
c'est la chose la plus
importante pour ces deux
chefs-là. Parce que sans avoir
la tribune de l'Assemblée
nationale, c'est
extraordinairement difficile de
réussir à maintenir son
pourcentage de votes. Je prends
le cas euh d'Éric Duhaime. On
s'entend il y a le mouvement
euh de réaction aux mesures euh
sur la covid a contribué à sa
montée. Et là il pourra pas
surfer là-dessus pour garder
son parti euh à un niveau
intéressant pendant 4 ans sans
avoir une une courroie de
transmission qui serait à
l'Assemblée nationale pour pour
se donner une image plus large
dans le cas du Parti Québécois
ça le Parti Québecois a
souffert beaucoup de pas avoir
Paul St-Pierre Plamondon à à
l'Assemblée nationale peuvent
pas se permettre un autre
mandat où ils ont pas de chef à
l'Assemblée nationale alors non
si il fallait qu'ils
choisissent entre les deux et
on leur demandera pas euh c'est
sûr que le choix à faire c'est
je veux être là parlez-en à
Maxime Bernier ah oui c'est
vrai qu'est-ce qui a permis à
monsieur Duhaime de prendre son
envol c'est quand le fait qu'il
ait eu une députée qui a quitté
la Coalition Avenir Québec pour
venir avec lui, qui lui donnait
accès au parlement, accès à la
tribune de la presse, accès aux
conférences de presse. Et à la
visibilité. Et il y a la
visibilité qui va avec. Ça
c'est ça qui a permis de
décoller. Alors il sait très
bien que s'il n'est pas à
l'Assemblée, il va avoir des
gros problèmes. Il nous reste
euh environ cinq minutes euh
Philippe hum combien il y a de
circonscriptions véritablement
surveillées euh lundi là euh
euh on dit qu'il y en a 125. En
réalité il y en a beaucoup qui
sont un peu décidés d'avance
là. Vous en surveillez combien
à peu près? Et j'ai je n'ai pas
envie de faire euh de faire
enlever les gens de le goût de
voter mais non quatre-vingt
circonscriptions qui ne
changeront pas de couleur quoi
qu'il arrive à moins d'un d'un
miracle. Et on parle d'un
miracle de sondage quand quand
les chiffres ont été aussi
stables aussi longtemps on peut
en douter. Donc quatre-vingt
circonscriptions que ça bougera
pas. Euh dans mon modèle
présentement j'ai 12 pivots et
13 Enclin donc un 25
circonscriptions qui pourraient
euh aller d'un bord ou de
l'autre selon les les les les
régions. Euh et j'ajoute à ça
vingt probables mon taux de
réussite chez les probables
c'est quatre-vingt-dix-sept.
Donc euh pas si mal. 3 % de
chance mais ça pourrait changer
alors euh oui on on regarde euh
tu sais il y a des
circonscriptions dans le
Bas-du-Fleuve, la Gaspésie
entre avec le PQ
circonscription à Montréal, QS
pourrait peut-être arrêter
quelques surprises, on regarde
l'Estrie, la capitale
nationale, la Beauce. Donc il y
a quelques pochettes de régions
comme ça qui pourraient être
intéressantes. Question
d'Alexandre Cadot qui euh je
pense vit à Québec puisqu'il
veut savoir dans Taschereau,
est-ce que Québec Solidaire va
être en mesure de garder sa
circonscription maintenant que
Catherine euh Dorion a quitté?
Je serais extrêmement surpris
si QS ne parvient pas euh à
garder Taschereau les autres
partis n'ont pas mis énormément
d'énergie dans cette
circonscription-là et c'est le
type de clientèle, la
démographie que qui est Québec
Solidaire cherche de toute
façon. Marie-Hélène, le vote
par anticipation a été
extrêmement populaire, c'est un
record, 24,5 % des électeurs
ont déjà voté. Euh ben on sait
que 100% ne vont pas voter, on
peut présumer que presque une
personne sur trois dans le fond
a déjà voté. Est-ce que ça
change euh la stratégie des
partis? Est-ce que dans le fond
euh euh la dernière semaine euh
un peu moins d'importance
qu'elle avait avant, Est-ce que
vous avez remarqué s'il y avait
une différence étant donné que
le vote par anticipation est
aussi populaire? Euh plus ou
moins euh François Legault a
une fin de campagne un peu à
l'image de celle de
deux-mille-dix-huit là,
c'est-à-dire qu'il est, il se
tient loin des grands centres,
euh fait peu de mêlées de
presse aussi euh donc pour
limiter euh visiblement le
risque d'erreur. Euh du côté
Dominique Anglade euh on va
quand même on on va quand même
aller à Kuujjuaq euh c'est la
première fois qu'un jeune se
rend là-bas euh aux Îles de la
Madeleine alors que dans un cas
comme dans l'autre les libéraux
ne sont pas dans le coup euh
elle a pourtant fort à faire à
Montréal et à Laval euh du côté
de de Québec Solidaire on est
plutôt en mode offensif là
c'est intéressant de voir euh
justement dans la région de
Montréal essentiellement même
dans Saint-Henri Saint-Jacques.
Circonscription de Dominique
Angla alors euh et du côté du
Parti Québécois ben on est dans
l'est euh aujourd'hui euh
c'était le cas hier également
parce qu'on veut préserver nos
acquis alors il y a pas
vraiment de de eu de mouvement
disons ou de changement dans
dans qui parce que et c'est
c'est en conformité en fait
avec les sondages avec ce qu'on
voit depuis un parti qui euh
tire davantage euh d'un vote
par anticipation aussi fort.
Yannick se demande est-ce que
ça va favoriser un, ça va
favoriser favoriser l'autre, à
quoi ça ressemble euh Philippe
le le vote parenti
définitivement la CAQ. La CAQ a
une domination lorsqu'on
découpe les sondages par
tranche d'âge. Les électeurs
plus âgés euh de façon
disproportionné par rapport à
ce qu'on a vu dans les
dernières élection semble se
ranger vers la CAQ et le vote
par anticipation. Bon c'est
fait bien sûr c'est pour tout
le monde mais il y a beaucoup
de personnes âgées. Euh donc
c'est sûr qu'il y a un avantage
quatre de ce côté-ci. Je suis
allé voter par anticipation pis
je suis un des plus jeunes. Euh
je j'osais pas le dire mais
j'ai eu la même expérience. En
passant je suis allée voir le
vote par anticipation en
Ontario. C'était en juin. Oui.
Neuf pour %. ah oui On est
ailleurs là. Ça a pas voté
beaucoup en Ontario.
Quarante-trois pour cent. C'est
le plus bas dans l'histoire. Il
me reste il me reste une minute
donc ça va passer rapidement
mais en quelques secondes
chacun vous surveillez quoi
précisément euh lundi Michel à
quoi vous allez être attentif?
Je me je me demande si la
mauvaise performance des
derniers jours de monsieur
Legault va jouer sur euh la
sortie de vote de la CAQ. Et si
ça ne peut pas causer quelques
surprises, ça c'est Philippe
qui nous le dira. Euh
Marie-Hélène vous surveille
lundi. Euh on surveille euh
justement moi je parce que bon
si on le dit c'est une bataille
pour la deuxième place. Alors
est-ce que le Parti Libéral va
parvenir à conserver
l'opposition officielle? Le
parti libéral n'a jamais fini
troisième. Alors imaginez ce
que ça pourrait représenter.
Euh pour ce parti quand même
qui a une longue histoire.
Okay. Chantal? Et qui
rejoindrait euh ces homologues
ontariens? Oui qui ont de la
difficulté à Ontario. Oui oui
complètement euh en arrière de
de dans les banquettes de
l'opposition. Euh moi je suis
très banale euh je fais les
circonscriptions des chefs euh
Dominique Anglade évidemment
mais aussi la circonscription
de Camille Laurin et euh
Chauveau. Euh moi je vais
surveiller en fait c'est ça euh
comme comme Chantal si Éric
Duhaime est à l'Assemblée
nationale ou s'il n'y est pas
c'est énormément différent. Si
le PQ a un seul siège ou s'il y
en a quatre ou cinq c'est
énormément différent pour les
quatre prochaines années et
pour 2026. Ah oui non ça il va
se passer des choses là d'ici
deux-mille-vingt-six. Merci
beaucoup à vous quatre.
J'espère que ça a été éclairant
pour nos éditeurs. Ça a été
fort intéressant certainement
de vous recevoir. Je rappelle
Marie-Hélène Tremblay, analyste
politique à Radio-Canada.
Michel Cauger, chroniqueur
politique à la presse et à
Radio-Canada, Chantal Hébert,
chroniqueur politique à
l'actualité et au Toronto Star
et Philippe Fournier, créateur
des sites Québec 125, 338
Canada. Merci beaucoup. Bonne
fin de campagne. On se retrouve
dans les euh prochains jours.
Merci Alex. Merci beaucoup. Je
prends quelques secondes pour
euh remercier mon équipe, un
gros merci à l'équipe technique
sur le plateau W ici à la
nouvelle Maison de
Radio-Canada, la réalisation
aussi pour le Facebook live.
Merci d'avoir été à l'écoute, à
la technique que
Charles-Antoine Lemay, Martin
Vaillancourt, Martin
Vaillancourt Lavoie, à la
recherche cette semaine,
dépendamment de la journée en
rotation. Karine Guillemette,
Geneviève Gagné, Mehdi Alaoui,
Emma Guerrero Dufour et Yohan
Dincent. Notre journaliste est
Annick Berreault à la
réalisation c'est de Dimitri
Kata d'autiste, notre
rédactrice en chef et Maryse
Gagnon. Je vous dis à lundi,
bonne fin de semaine. À très
bientôt.